هنا الاردن سنربط الاحزمه استعدادا
للانطلاق في جوله سياحيه نلف بها البلاد
خلال دقائق البدايه عمان حيث سياحه الاثار
حاضر
فمن جبل القلعه الى المدرج الروماني تذكره
الزمن تعود بالسائح لالاف السنين
[موسيقى]
المتعه لم تبدا بعد خاصه مع انضمام الاردن
لافضل 30 وجه سياحيه عالميه على مستوى
العالم للعام 2013
فان كانت الوجهه للسياحه العلاجيه فالطريق
لاخفض بقعه في العالم حيث يستقبلك البحر
الميت فيما ستكون حمامات ماعين بانتظارك
بشلالاتها الساخنه
وان كنت من محبي المغامره فما عليك سوى
الذهاب لجبال عجلون و وادي الموجب لتكون
ما بين تسلق الجبال تاره والغوص في المياه
تاره اخرى
[موسيقى]
للتاريخ حكايه ادخلها عجائب الدنيا السبع
المدينه الورديه هذه حكايه البتراء التي
تعد ايضا احدى وجهات ما يعرف بالمثلث
الذهبي صحراء وجبالها تستوقفك بسحرها
الفريد يستمر المسير حتى العقبه مدينه
سياحه الاردنيه بامتياز حيث البحر واعماقه
التي يتفرد بها عن باقي بحار العالم
[موسيقى]
لف وجهه باختلا رغبه السائح وكله الخيارات
متاحه
نتجه للشمال حيث جرش مدينه الاثار
الرومانيه مدينه تجمع الفن والثقافه
والتاريخ وتقدم كافه الخيارات لزوارها
معانا الان الى جبل نيبو والمغطس ومادبا
حيث تتفردوا هذه الاماكن بالسياحه الدينيه
لم تنتهي الجوله بعد لكن الرحله على وشك
الانتهاء فان اردت اكمالها فما عليك الا
زياره الاردني لاستكشافها كبلد تميز وتفرد
على خارطه السياحه العالميه
[موسيقى]